Zu denken, was man sagt, oder zu meinen, was man fühlt, zu hören, was dich tief bewegt und was in deiner Seele wühlt, dem allem wirklich zu entgehen, bekommt man nicht so einfach hin, es sei denn man hört nur das Puffo mit Stefan und Florentin. Das soll sich auch nie gesehen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge, das Hi Podcast. Ich wollte es jetzt mal kurz machen, einfach ein Hi, Hi, Hey, Heya! Schön, dass ihr da seid, natürlich wieder vor mir sitzen, Stefan Tietze, er will nicht gehen, die Einladung ist mittlerweile ein bisschen überstrapaziert, ich habe ihn für die ersten drei Folgen hinzugebeten als technischen Assistenten. Ja, aber hat doch gut funktioniert. Deswegen dachte ich, bleibe ich noch ein bisschen. Und gegenüber von mir sitzt der Gastgeber des Podcast-Sofos, Flo Hinton Will. Der alleinige Gastgeber. Richtig. Und wie ihr gerade gehört habt, war Lothar2, der uns dieses fantastische Intro geschickt hat. Vielen, vielen Dank an Lothar. Wir sind mittlerweile schon so weit, dass selbst der Vorname Lothar schon die Zahl zwei danach verlangt. Verlangt, weil so viele Lothars haben schon Intros eingeschickt. Ich glaube, wir sind mittlerweile bei Philipps sieben,
bei Paul acht, bei Matthias drei,
wir sind sogar bei Estefania vier,
also wir haben wirklich schon eine Menge
Hörerintros verballert. Wir können übrigens jetzt
auch Rückschlüsse auf die Häufigkeit von Namen.
Also keine
wirklich spannende Statistik, aber zumindest
sind wir jetzt an dem Punkt, wo wir Statistiken
erheben können. Es gibt niemanden, der Lena heißt.
Denn, das haben wir rausgefunden. Unsere Hörerschaft ist eine repräsentative Menge. So, von denen haben wir jetzt, wie viele, wann haben wir zum ersten Mal Intros, externe Intros? 150, 100, so was macht man keine Statistiken. So was, 150, 100, 150, so was. Statistische Bundesamt ist auch immer so. Drei, drei. Ja, so Pi mal Daumen. Hängt da irgendwo an der Wand so ein Pi mal Daumen und dann so durchgestrichen, so rot durchgestrichen, so ein Verbotsschild. Ja. Weil das ist ja eben nicht Pi mal Daumen. Komisch, ne, dass du im Englischen hast du Rule of Thumb und im Deutschen hast du Pi mal Daumen.
Also der Daumen scheint noch eine Rolle zu spielen, aber die Deutschen haben gesagt, nee, wir nehmen noch unseren alten Dreier mit rein, weil wir sind ja so viel schlauer.
Pi mal Daumen mal E hoch zwei hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Das war ja eigentlich der Vorschlag.
Aber ich habe auch gerade, wo du das wiederholt hast, noch nie gehört, dass jemand gesagt hat Pi mal Daumen.
Irgendwie hat man da überlegt, das E N wegzulassen, Pi mal Daumen. Irgendwie hat man da überlegt, das En wegzulassen, Pi mal Daumen.
Daumen? Daumen.
Weiß ich gar nicht. Sagt man Daumen?
Ich sag Daumen nicht, ich sag Daumen.
Das ist auch so ein Wort, das sehr schnell seine Bedeutung verliert, Daumen.
Ich denke Daumen.
Aber da müsste man eine Rangliste erstellen von Worten, die schnell ihre Bedeutung verlieren
und welche, die langsam ihre Bedeutung verlieren.
Daumen muss man zwei, dreimal sagen und ich bin komplett woanders. ich habe das Wort da noch nie gehört. Christoph Daumen. Dauben. Könnte auch ein B mit drin sein, Dauben. Dauben. Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es vom hochdeutschen Wort, mittelalterlichen Wort Dauben kommt. Im Grunde. Die Daubenquetsche, kennt man ja. Beliebte Foltermethode. Brauchen wir noch Daumen oder ist die Zeit vorbei? Wir haben ja ursprünglich, also zum Beispiel, ein Krokodil kann ja nahezu nichts, also kann nicht Schlagzeug spielen. Weder singen noch tanzen. Kann nicht singen, kann nicht tanzen, Schlagzeug spielen, Fagott, vergiss es, keine Chance mit einem Krokodil. Warum? Weil es keinen opposable thumb hat, also der Daumen ist nicht auf der anderen Seite der anderen Quetschkunde. Du musst aber kurz in die Sprache flüchten, in der du die Dokumentation gehört hast. Ich muss kurz, wo ich von Louis C.K. gehört habe, wie er das schon mal erzählt hat. Ich denke mir auch, ich verrate mich so oft mit der Sprache, wenn ich plötzlich in Spanische flüchte und man merkt, ah, da hat er die Dokumentation geguckt. Er hat schon wieder von Pablo Ecefalia geklaut. Er hat schon wieder von Duolingo, hat seinen Effekt geklaut. Wohingegen der Mensch hat ja irgendwann gesagt, lass mal den Quatsch mit den Krallen und hat den Daumen gegenübergestellt. Und ab dann war alles möglich, Querflöte, Flug zum Mond, kein Problem. Mittlerweile könnte man sagen, vielleicht lass uns mal wieder einen Schritt zurückgehen. Vielleicht brauchen wir wieder den Glattdaumen auf der einen Seite, damit wir wieder schneller laufen können auf unseren Vorderpflogen. Wir haben ja eben nicht nur mit dem Daumen die Rakete zum Mond geschossen, sondern auch die Rakete auf unsere lieben Mitmenschen. So, und deswegen kann man jetzt ja als Natur überlegen, uns den Daumen wiederz nehmen. Das Daumen ist so ein Geschenk von so einer ausserirdischen Macht. Ja, oder der Double Daumen, dass man sagt, so sind die Nämlich. Ihr könnt offensichtlich nicht damit umgehen, ihr seid noch nicht reif genug, nehme ich es wieder weg. Ja, wie Erik aus der gelben Klasse, nee, wie heißt das im Kindergarten Gruppe? Aus der gelben Gruppe, Erik weiß ich noch, damals Leuten mit einer Schere die Ohren eingeschnitten. Wo man sagt, dann nimmt man Erik nicht, also er hätte ihm auch den Daumen nehmen sollen, rückblickend, aber man hat ihm eine Schere wieder genommen. Ich denke mir, so ist es auch so, wenn es irgendwo so eine Matrix oder so eine Alienmacht gibt, die jetzt sieht, was wir mit unseren Daumen alles für einen Scheiss gemacht haben, dann haben die einfach so einen Schalter und dann sagen, wie so Eltern sagen, nö, das war es jetzt. Es gibt natürlich pädagogisch auch den genau anderen Ansatz, dass man dann sagt, also wie zum Beispiel dieses klassische, das Kind raucht eine Zigarette. Das Kind raucht eine Zigarette. Das Kind raucht eine Zigarette und es wird dazu gezwungen, die ganze Schachtel aufzurauchen. Oh mein Gott. Und mit der Hoffnung, dass es dann so angewidert ist, dass es nie wieder raucht, weil es das dann verbindet.
Also kann man auch sagen, Bernd aus der gelben Gruppe, du kriegst jetzt zehn Scheren, in jedem Finger kriegst du eine Schere und guck mal, wie weit du damit kommst. Jetzt musst du von allen, weil man es auch falsch überträgt, von allen die Ohren abschneiden. So, mal gucken, wie lange dir das Spaß macht, wo man nicht genau weiß, also aus mir wird kein Pädagoge, glaube ich. Ich glaube nicht, aber da könnte auch die Natur sagen, nee, wenn das mit dem gegenüberliegenden Daumen so gut funktioniert hat, dann kriegst du jetzt alle Finger gegenüberliegen. Dann hast du richtig gegenüberliegenden Kopf. Hallo, Entschuldigung? Boah, das ist ja ganz merkwürdig. Wir sind in einer professionellen Situation. Hallo? Hallo? Ja, wäre es okay, wenn ich zurückrufe? Ich bin gerade mitten in einer Aufnahme. Kann ich in einer Stunde zurückrufen, sowas? Super, danke. Das ist ein hochbrisanter Anruf. Ja, das war leider ein sehr hochbrisanter Anruf. Das war ein hochbrisanter Anruf. Extrem brisanter Anruf. Aber wie unprofessionell von dir das Mikrofon in so einer Aufnahmsituation, dass du das Handy nicht ausmachst. Ja, das tut mir leid. Das nehme ich zurück. Nee, du wirst jetzt gerne das Handy wegnehmen. Oder du musst immer, wenn du angerufen wirst, drangehen jetzt in Zukunft. Und ich muss es dann laut, ich muss dann auf Lautstärke stellen. Okay, ist das der Deal ab jetzt? Wir beiden, mark our words and I know you will. Für den Rest dieses Podcasts müssen wir die Anrufer laut annehmen. Okay. Okay, gut. Hört unseren Handschlag. Das ist eine Pädagogik, die hoffentlich funktioniert. So könnte ich es in der Tür aber auch machen, dass sie einfach sagt, okay, jetzt kriegt ihr den Finger auch noch auf die andere Seite. Also, dass die Finger nicht mehr eins, vier sind, sondern drei, zwei, dass du sowohl den Daumen als auch den Zeigefinger auf der anderen Seite hast. Weißt du, was ich jetzt finde? Doppelt gemoppelt, finde ich das. Doppelt gemoppelt? Warum findest du die vier Finger auf der einen Seite nicht vierfach gemoppelt?
Das fände ich doppelt doppelt gemoppelt gemoppelt.
Zwei hoch zwei gemoppelt. Ja, das fände ich doppelt hoch zwei.
Ich wäre eher für einen gegenüberliegenden Kopf einer, der einmal mitdenken kann.
Du willst dir konstant selbst in die Augen schauen müssen?
Ja, weil ich glaube nicht, dass wir dann auf unsere lieben Mitmenschen, wenn wir uns die ganze Zeit selbst sehen, als Mensch wahrnehmen auch, als Teil dieser Erde, dann würden wir nicht, lass mich ausreden, dann würden wir nicht eine Rakete auf unsere lieben Mitmenschen geschossen. Da hätten wir nur zum Mond geschossen. Und auf den gegenüberliegenden Mond. Du willst zwei Köpfe haben, von denen einer so ausgerichtet ist, dass er direkt
vor dir ist, wie so eine GoPro, die so dein
Gesicht fähig. Ja, wie dieser Fisch mit der Laterne
vorne dran. Und der schaut dich die...
Aber ist es dann nochmal genau dein Gesicht?
Ja. Ja, und
kann der auch was? Oder kann der
auch sehen und denken? Nee, es ist nur so ein Reminder.
Ah,
da ist ja noch jemand. Ich bin ja jemand. Wie man das manchmal hat, wenn man in den Spiegel guckt. Das vergisst du, dass du jemand bist? Vergessen wir nicht manchmal, ich weiß auch nicht genau, wo ich mit diesem Exkurs hin will, aber vergessen wir nicht manchmal, wer wir sind, wo wir herbekommen und worum es eigentlich gehen sollte. Um Freunde, um Liebe. Machen wir es so, kannst du machen bei den Frettchen, aber die Menschen lassen wir erstmal so. Den Frettchen kannst du dieses zweite weirde Gesicht ranbasteln, dann kannst du mal gucken, auf welche Liebe mit Frettchen, die ihre Raketen schießen. Ja, aber so fing das doch an, das Brainstorming, am Ende war dann dieser Anglerfisch, da hat man halt eine Lampe bekommen. Ja, genau. Wir gucken mal bei dem, ob es klappt, und wenn es da klappt, dann übertragen wir es auf den Menschen. Aber erst mal so diese ganzen armen Tiere, die für irgendwelche dummen Ideen herhalten mussten, als man gesagt hat, lass es mal da machen, lass mal irgendwie einen, der kann die Farbe ändern, Menschen können die Farbe ändern, lass uns erst mal irgendwie so einen Oktopoden geben. Das Versuchskaninchen, ja, aber das kann nicht die Farbe ändern. Ja, tolle Doku auf Netflix, mein Lehrer das Oktopus und und nein, Entschuldigung, mein Lehrer der Krakel. Ich habe mir nur gemerkt, dass der Artikel strange war. Ach so. Und habe es einfach on the fly. Und jetzt rückblickend schon achtmal
falsch empfohlen.
Richtig. Nee, mein
Lehrer der Krake. Kraken?
Nee, mein Lehrer der Krake.
Wo wir da bei
Futter-Garibik wären, wo es ja die
große Diskussion ist, ob es der Kraken
oder der Krake ist. Was genial
ist erstmal, um
Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen auf den Titel. Also wenn du nicht sagst, der Herr der Ringe, sondern das Herr der Ringe und alle so, hä, jetzt muss ich es anschauen, weil du hast eine offene Frage, so wie, die Herr der Ringe, was ist das, was soll das? Ich freue mich auch jedes Mal so, wenn der Titel des Films im Film vorkommt. Roll Credits. Ja, ich liebe das. Toll. Ich freue mich dann immer. Ich muss dann immer grinsen. Immer so eine kleine Faust. Aber nur ganz klein für mich. Wenn man für sich ist, macht man die Bewegung nicht groß. Kein Auflauchzen. Also zumindest so eine geballte Faust. So ein seliges Grinsen. Und mein Lehrer der Krake ist eine weirde Doku, ehrlich gesagt, von jemandem, der irgendwie halt Zeit hat und sich dann mit einem Kraken anfreundet, der aber weiblich ist. Also, es ist ein weiblicher Krake.
Oktopaar.
Ein weiblicher Krake.
Oktopar. Ein weiblicher Krake.
Und
ja, weirde Geschichte, weil
die erst...
Wir haben zu viel mit der Grammatik
verbracht, zu wenig mit dem Inhalt.
Also wenn sie in Zukunft ihre Rezensionen
ein bisschen anpassen könnten,
also, weil
uns haben uns ein paar Nachrichten erreicht von unseren Lesern, dass sie sich mehr über den Inhalt wünschen sollen. Weil sie haben jetzt auch zum Beispiel unten unsere beliebten Kategorien, wenn man dann irgendwie Spannung, drei Stern, Erotik, das hat sich ja bewährt, Anspruch, das sind ja die Kategorien, in denen wir seit Jahren denken. Sie haben jetzt Grammatik, Semantik und ich weiß nicht, ob das die Kategorien sind, in denen wir denken sollten. Ja, aber ich dachte mir vor allem, also Fazit, hätte nicht noch ein Komma gepasst zwischen mein Lehrer, der Krake. Hätte da nicht ein Komma und oder ein Semikolon Platz gefunden. Also warum fand sie den Film Jungfrau 40 männlich sucht nicht gut? Naja, weder Anführungszeiten noch Semikolon, er hätte im Bindestrich reingehört,
also von mir drei von zehn Semikoli, mehr nicht. Oh mein Gott. Aber ja, ich sag mal mehr nicht zum Inhalt, weil ich will ja auch nicht viel spoilern. Ja, ich hätte gerne ein bisschen mehr zum Inhalt gesagt. Naja, es geht halt um einen Krake, der halt Sachen macht und dann denkt man sich, uh, da Da kommt jetzt so ein Hai und frisst den, schnappt den, wie heissen diese Nudeln, die ...
Ramen. der halt Sachen macht und dann denkt man sich, da kommt jetzt so ein Hai und frisst den, schnappt den, wie heissen diese Nudeln, die Rahmen, die Tentakel weg. Aber dann denkt man sich, ah fuck, aber dann wächst der nach und dann denkt man sich, ja dann passt es doch. Oktopelpass? Ich habe es aber nur mit halbem Auge geguckt, weil ich mir dann daneben die ganze Zeit auf Duolingo gegoogelt habe, ob das wirklich der Krage ist. Ich war wirklich komplett raus. Also vielleicht ist es doch nicht so gut, vielleicht willst du doch nicht, dass die ganzen Kinozuschauer dann nebenbei am Handy sitzen und die ganze Zeit, warum sagt er das immer so, warum sagt er immer das Kommentar und der Momentum und so und das Moment und so, was soll das eigentlich die ganze Zeit? Und alle gucken die ganze Zeit und die ganze Actionsequenz, wo irgendjemand vom Hochhaus gefallen ist und sich das Genick gebrochen hat. Niemand kann das wertschätzen, wegen der Grammatik. Ja, ein bisschen hilft mir dann immer Twitter. Und da hat mir auch geholfen, wenn man Dinge zusammen geguckt hat, damals noch. Wisst ihr noch, als wir noch zusammen uns so ein Hashtag ausgesucht haben für irgendeine Sendung und alle live geguckt haben, weil dann hatten immer alle das Problem. Dann war häufig, dann denkt man sich was und dann will man das twittern und dann sieht man, dass schon acht Leute die Frage gestellt haben. Das Max Bierhals, Patrick Stenzel und die anderen Neomagazinnasen haben das dann schon getwittert, Tobi Schmidt auch natürlich. Und man macht dieselben Gags mit denselben Leuten, wie man es auch auf der Arbeit machen würde.
Nur mit falscher Grammatik.
Mit falscher Grammatik liegt es dann.
Ha, Freizeit. Ist das nicht herrlich?
Freizeit, Liebe ist. Man treibt mit denen, die man auch mit denen drauf arbeitet.
Und ja, aber da wird es dann besprochen.
So, da hättest du dann die Frage nicht, heißt es das Moment oder der Moment.
Ja.
Aber ich finde, bei dem Moment sollte man sich auch mal einigen.
Keine Ahnung. Ich habe das Gefühl, die Leute machen, was sie wollen, haben irgendwie keine Disziplin und niemand achtet drauf irgendwie. Vielleicht sollten wir dieses ganze Sprachsthema auch einfach sagen, jetzt mach was, mach was, was ihr wollt. Hey, hey, hey. Niemand korrigiert mehr, niemand macht mir hier, das sind 2M, 3M. Macht ihr das ein Ding? Ich glaube, wir müssen das nochmal so durchmischen, weil es gibt ja auch oft so Phasen in der Sprache, wo die gesagt haben, jetzt machen wir alles anders, einfach mal alle Schotten auf und los geht's. Diese Storyline darf nicht weitergehen. Und los geht's und jeder macht einfach mal guckt mal, wie er weiterkommt. Aber es ist ja tatsächlich so, das ist zum Beispiel so, ich schreibe ab und zu mit jemandem über Facebook und der schreibt alles richtig. Das ist ein Facebook-Freund. Perfekte Rechtschreibung. Das ist ein Brieffreund. Ja genau, ein Facebook-Freund. Der schreibt alles richtig, außer das Wort Halt. Ja, oh mein Gott. Also dieses, ja da muss man halt mal drüber wegsehen. Ja, ein Abtönungspartikel. Genau, und schreibt mit D. Oh Gott. Aber alles andere richtig. Und dann denke ich immer so, wie kann, weil wenn jemand wirklich alles falsch schreibt oder so, dann denke ich mal, gut, okay, passt schon. Aber wenn jemand alles richtig schreibt, außer einer Sache und das ist dann noch so ein komisches Halbwort, das gar nicht richtig existiert, so ein Glitchwort, so ein bisschen ähm, so wie Luft holen, soll man das dann korrigieren und wie? Urlaub fürs Hirn so ein bisschen an dem Moment. Moment Urlaub fürs Hirn. Ja, so ein bisschen Pause, so ein Satzpause für den Kopf. Aber was hast du dann gemacht, hast du das angesprochen oder lässt du es einfach über dich ergehen und wirst du dann auch wütend, je mehr du schreibst mit der Person. Ich werde wütend, ich habe es noch nicht angesprochen, weil das ist ja so ein bisschen das Äquivalent von, man hat irgendwie Spinat in der Nase oder so und wo man dann sagen muss, das muss man jemandem sagen, sonst rennt er den ganzen Tag rum und alle halten ihn für bescheuert, weil er Spinat in der Nase hat und als guter Freund hätte man eigentlich sagen müssen, hey, du hast Spinat in der Nase. Aber warum halten die alle für bescheuert? Genau so ist nämlich, weil der schreibt mit allen anderen Menschen auch und alle denken, was für ein Trottel, der kann das Wort nicht schreiben und ich hätte eigentlich die Verantwortung, ihn zu korrigieren, mach's aber nicht. Ja, aber warum halten die alle für bescheuert, weil wie soll das Spinat dahingekommen sein? Du hast es ja gesehen. Du hast es ja gesehen. Du warst mit der Person Essen zum Beispiel und du siehst, wie das Stück Spinat fälschlicherweise war so nicht vorhergesehen im Gesicht landet. Also, er hatte erstmal eine schöne Pizzaspinacci sich gegönnt und hat dann tatsächlich noch, als die Pizza kam, nochmal Olivenöl auf die Pizza drauf getan. Genau. Wobei ich dachte, stopp, wenn Olivenöl dann vorm Backen bitte, war bei ihm anders, habe ich auch nicht angesprochen, habe ich schon mal durchgehen lassen. Oder war es noch Knoblauchöl, hast du durchgehen lassen? Ne, ne, ne, habe ich durchgegnissen, war schon eine gelbe Karte. Und dann hat er die Spinacci Mangiare und dann hatte er aber Spinacci con Dento, also in den Zähnen. Endento. Aldento. Aldento. Spinacci al dente. Ja. Und hatte die zwischen den Zähnen, da habe ich gesagt, pass auf, du hast das Spinac zwischen den Zähnen. Du bist mein alter Zahnarzt. Praxis al dente. Wirklich? Wirklich? Ja, weil es ja all about dente geht. Oh nein, aber jetzt sag mir nicht, dass jetzt Zahnärzte anfangen mit diesen Wortspielen. Wir sind Friseur-Wortpielen. Oh nein. Wir sind am Zahn der Zeit. Oh Gott, am Zahn der Zeit. Oh nein. Furchtbar. Ja, genau. Wir sind kurz abgeschwommen. Genau, er hatte Spinacci al dente und dann habe ich gesagt, excusez-moi, du hast da Pomodoro. So. Und dann hat er einen Zahnstöcher genommen, von diesen Zahnstöchern, die aber in Papier eingepackt sind, hat dann das aufgerissen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie du es machst, aber ich steche immer so durch. Gibt es, aber bei mir kommt die immer auf der falschen Seite raus. Kommt immer auf der falschen Seite raus. Jetzt habe ich mir vorgenommen, direkt auf der falschen Seite das zu machen, damit es aus der richtigen
rauskommt. Nee, bei mir auch immer, ich drücke den Daumen auf eine Seite, drücke raus und der Zahnstocher fährt vier Zentimeter in den Daumen rein, tiefste
Blutwunde. In den Daumen. Und ich sag, ich dussel, blut alles voll und so, muss dann neue, auch die Serviette aus der Papiertüte
raus. Man versucht zu überspielen, wusstest du, was Daumen früher, Dauben heißt, wir wissen sie, ja gut So, dass der Daumen ursprünglich kein Finger ist und so weiter und so weiter, etc, etc, etc, pp, pp, pp und dann nimmt er eben den Zahnstocher raus und will den Spinat aus den Zähnen rausnehmen, aber macht es mit einer solchen Wucht, dass er das Spinacci katapultiert
in die Nase hoch.
Ach Gott. Und dann ist die
Frage, sagt man, und dann hat er
gefragt, ist es weg, deutend auf seine
Zähne, und ich habe gesagt, so wie du die Frage stellst,
ja, muss ich dir sagen, ja.
Si claro, aber
ich bin nicht der Umhingekommen, dann
noch zu sagen, jetzt haben wir aber noch
ein, jetzt muss ich ganz kurz nochmal auf dieses Spinatthema zurückkommen. Auf Spinatrate eingehen. Du hast das Problem nur verschoben, nicht gelöst. Ich erläutere mal. Das habe ich dann nicht übers Herz bekommen, weil ich dachte, es gibt auch nur so viel, wie man von jemandem verlangen kann bei einem Abendessen. Irgendwann ist Schluss, irgendwann geht nicht so. Du kannst einfach nicht sagen, jetzt ist genug. Wenn da jemand kommt, hat Hosenstahl offen, Spinat zwischen den Zähnen, hat die Brille falsch rum um, hat den T-Shirt falsch rum an und man sagt, nee, ich bin den ganzen Abend damit beschäftigt, die Person darauf hinzuweisen. Eine Alteration, eine Änderung kannst du vornehmen. Eine Korrektur pro Abend, mehr geht nicht. Nicht unten Hosenstall ist offen und Frisur ist falsch. Der hat noch schön Zahnpasta am Mundwinkel, alles noch drin, eine Kontaktlinse drin, die andere nicht, kann ich nicht mit umgehen. So, und dann hat er eben Spinat in der Nase und dann habe ich ihm auch gesagt, da ist Schluss. Ja, genau, und dann hast du aber gerade gesagt, eingangs, dieser Person hast du jetzt gesagt, da ist Spinat, so, und dann geht die durch die Welt, damit sie nicht wie ein kompletter Vollidiot ist. Aber du bist ja nur in dieser, sagen wir mal, Verbundenheitssituation, weil du mit dabei warst, wo der Unfall passiert ist. Du hast von A bis Z die ganze Geschichte, the whole shebang, hast du mitbekommen.
Jetzt denken aber andere ja auch nicht, dass es ein Vollidiot ist, sondern da ist wohl ein bisschen Spinat hängen geblieben. Also warum bist du jetzt der Heilige in dieser Situation? Warum bist du jetzt da so ein verschworenes Team? Warum stellst du dich jetzt über die anderen Menschen, die denken, es ist ein Vollidiot? Weil das ist ja ... Die denken jetzt auch nicht, oh, was ist ein Vollidiot, der hat versucht, den Spinat einzuinhalieren. Nein, die denken wahrscheinlich nicht genau das, was passiert ist. Ja, aber ich finde, man hat trotzdem die Verantwortung, weil ich kann jetzt sagen, okay, von mir ist der Schaden schon angerichtet, alle anderen kann ich noch bewahren sozusagen. Aber es stimmt schon, eigentlich ist es eine schwierige moralische Situation, die du aufwirfst.
Und gut, du hast mich durch deine moralische Schäbigkeit auf den Boden der Tatsache zurückgeholt und jetzt fühle ich mich besser.
Wo wir gerade bei unangenehmen sozialen Situationen sind.
Ja, so, du hast mir eine Hausaufgabe aufgegeben. Es gab eine Hausaufgabe. Ganz kurz der Flashback.
Du gehst immer in einen Kiosk, holst eine Mate und und jedes Mal, wenn er eine Mate kauft, was häufig der Fall ist, sagt der Mann hinter einem Kiosk, der Kioskbesitzer sagt, lecker Mate.
Lecker Mate. Immer wenn er die Mate scannt. Für uns natürlich ein gefundenes Fressen, um uns zum einen zu untersuchen auf unsere Konfliktfreude oder eben nicht unsere Angst vor Konflikten. Und deswegen habe ich dir auch so ein bisschen konfrontationstherapeutisch mit auf den Weg gegeben, das mal zu lösen. Auch um das Problem einfach aus der Welt zu schaffen, weil man kann ihm ja nicht direkt sagen, sag's nicht mehr. Das ist ja, wo kommen wir denn da hin? Und letzte Woche, ich habe es nicht, ich habe es nicht, ich habe es nicht gemacht, Hausaufgabe nicht gemacht. Du hast die Hausaufgaben vergessen. Du hast mir nicht geglaubt, dass ich die Hausaufgabe im Bus habe liegen lassen. Heute komme ich mit dem Beweis, ich habe sie doch nur im Bus liegen lassen, ich habe sie tatsächlich gemacht. Aber die ganze Sache verkompliziert sich noch ein wenig. Oh mein Gott. Du hast mich nämlich letzte Woche, und das möchte ich jetzt auch mal ansprechen, nach der Aufnahme noch richtig fertig gemacht. Du hast mich richtig an die Kandare genommen. Es sind Tränen geflossen. Es sind auf beiden Seiten drei von vier Augen haben geweint. Mehr bei mir. Wenn ich sagen, mehr wissen. An was habe ich dich gebunden? Du hast mich an die Kandare genommen. Hä? Was ist denn die Kandare? Ich weiss es doch nicht, keine Ahnung. Und dann hast du, also ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr euch das vorstellen könnt, weil ihr erlebt Stefan immer so als heiteren Gesellen, der irgendwie einen lockeren Spruch zu allen Situationen hat, aber du kannst wirklich ernst werden, also wirklich tief ernst und auch wirklich mit einer, deine Stimme ändert sich, es wird tiefer, es wird bebend, da ist eine Emotionalität drin und man hat so wirklich dieses Gefühl, wenn ich jetzt ein Widerwort sage, dann fange ich mir eine. Du baust dich vor mir auf. Ich sass. Ich will es ja nicht kommen. Es ist einfach auch eine Machtdemonstration in dem Moment. Also ich weiß ja auch, wie ich mich dann geben muss. Ja, vor allem ich sass, du stehst auf, baust dich vor mir auf, redest energisch auf mich ein. Ich selber stelle mir die Frage, ab welchem Punkt soll ich auch aufstehen, um dir Parodie zu bieten? Kann ich überhaupt aufstehen oder ist es unangenehm? Um mich während du noch an den Dachen geschnallt bist, mir Paroli zu bieten. Genau. Und also auf jeden Fall war ich sehr eingeschüchtert und dann dachte ich mir, nee, diese Woche kann ich nicht nochmal enttäuschen, sonst fange ich mir wirklich eine. Du fängst dir eine und sind auch schon Leute aus dem Nebenraum angekommen und gefragt, war alles okay. Ja, weil du meintest, sollte ich nicht bis nächste Woche die Hausaufgabe erfüllen, würdest du mir mit deinen Beinen auf dem Bauch herumtrommeln, mir einen Tritt verpassen, so hast du es formuliert, einen Tritt mit beiden Beinen auf meinen Bauch. Also du hast mir das bildlich vor Augen geführt. Augengefühl, dass auch ein paar Mal versprochen. Man ist ja auch, das kennt man ja, wenn man sehr wütend ist, kommt ja auch nicht jeder Satz direkt nach dem anderen. Du hast gesagt, ich würde für den Fall, dass du das nächste Woche nicht hast, würde ich Anlauf nehmen und dann mit einem Sprung mit beiden Füssen gegen deinen Bauch treten mit vereinten Kräften. Beide Beine auf dem Bauch. Verein ihre Kräfte. Verein ihre Kräfte. Und du meintest auf die Gefahr, dass ich dann selbst wie ein Töpel auf den Boden plumpse. Ich habe mich verrannt. Das wäre es mir wert. Und dann bist du rausgegangen, sie Tür hinter dir zugeschlagen. Aber ich habe sie erst nicht so erwischt. Also war es erst so ein Schlag ins Leere, der mich dann noch wütender gemacht hat. Das ist übrigens auch spannend, wenn man sehr wütend auf jemanden ist und dann macht man irgendwas doofes und dann wird man noch wütender, wenn man nicht weiss mit Wut. Und dann muss ich immer zurückgehen, um die so richtig doll zu schlagen. Aber es hat dann irgendwie, ah! Ja, du hattest deine Schuhe nicht an, du ziehst ja immer zur Aufnahme mit den Schuhen an, das heißt, du musstest noch sehr wütend deine Schuhe anziehen, was unangenehm lange gedauert hat. Kann man nicht gut. Man kann nicht. Schnürsenkel binden ist niedlich. Es ist kernniedlich. Weil eine Schleife ist süss. Eine Schleife ist süss. Es gibt nicht die, doch, es gibt schon diese Skater, deswegen machen die Skater es ja nicht, die Vans tragen. Die stopfen ja ihre Schnürsenkel rechts und links rein. Ja, aber so cool sind wir nicht, das können wir uns nicht leisten. Nee. Und dann macht man es, was ich nie verstanden habe, ist einmal hintenrum und dann erst reinstecken, damit die dann kürzer sind, aber dann kam bei mir immer hinten das wieder hoch.
Und dann sah es so aus, als ob ich so ein Knöchel-Freundschaftsarmband getragen habe. Also es ist so eine Downward-Spiral in Richtung soziale Vernichtung gewesen. Nein, ich glaube wirklich, wenn du deinen Erzfeind sehen würdest, wie er sich die Schuhe zubindet, man hätte Mitleid.
Man würde sagen, man kann jemanden nicht hassen, er sich die Schuhe zubindet, man hätte
Mitleid. Man würde sagen, man kann jemanden nicht hassen, der sich
die Schuhe zubindet, weil entweder du machst so dieses
Häschenohr durch
Schlaufe oder halt
Baby ist kalt, der Schal. Genau. Ich glaube,
wenn du Adolf Hitler siehst, wie er sich
die Schuhe bindet, sagst du, no.
Weil entweder hat er diese süsten Schnürsenkel,
die schön braunen, oder
halt Klettverschluss. Ich glaube, er war ein Kletter. War er ein Kletter? Ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, niemand war damals ein Kletter. Wann wurde ein Kletterverschluss erfunden? Weiß ich nicht, als Reaktion auf, ich weiß es gar nicht. Gab es nicht die große Klettverschlussverbrennung, weil er ein Gegner war? Ich weiß es gar nicht. Ich meine schon. Aber auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, er könnte auch ein Kletter gewesen sein. Einfach schön. Und ja, du bist rausgestürmt und ich hatte sehr viel Angst die ganze Woche und habe es dann über mich gebracht, erneut. Also wir haben ja gesagt, zwei Experimente. Erstens, was anderes als Mate kaufen, dass man sich da irgendwie so ein Grapefruit... Weil ich wollte wissen, sagt der immer lecker Mate oder sagt der einfach auch lecker Fritz-Cola? Ja. Weil das gilt es natürlich zu verzehentlich. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, was könnte ich kaufen? Hast du beide Tasks gemacht? Langsam. Okay, Gott, ich bin ganz aufgeregt. Und erst dachte ich mir, ich hole mir ein Grapefruit-Granini, sagte dann, oh, lecker Grapefruit-Granini. Oh, aber auch gefährlich, weil Alliteration, weil Eselsbrächer, also, nee, was ist das Zungenbrecher? Eselsbrücke, Zungenbrecher. Grapefruit-Granini kann man auch nicht, also lecker Grapefruit-Granini ist an sich schon mal schwierig auszusprechen. Ja, Punica fruchtig rot hatte ich auch noch in der Hinterhand. Was ist, wenn ich zwei Sachen kaufe, oh, lecker Grapefruit-Granini und Punica fruchtig rot. Aber er sagt ja nie lecker Mate Mate. Nee, stimmt. Er sagt nur, also er sagt die Oberkategorie, er sagt die Gattung. Ja genau, ist es dann, ja, Fruchtsaftkonzentrat mit über drei Prozent Fruchtsaft, ich weiß es nicht, auf jeden Fall war ich bereit und ich kaufe einen und es ist etwas passiert, womit ich nicht gerechnet habe. Und ich habe mir die Situation schon vorgestellt. Wie wird das sein? Ich habe diese Granini-Flasche in der Hand. Ist die zu schwer für eine Hand? Und dann war ich da, hole mir eben diese Grapefruit-Granini und er hat telefoniert. Ja, aber jetzt ganz ehrlich, Versuchsabbruch. Unlautere Bedingungen. Ich war nicht in der Verfassung, das Experiment an der Stelle zu beenden, zu terminieren. Ich hatte bereits den Fruchtsaft aus der Kühltruhe entfernt und man darf den dann nicht mehr zurücklegen. Weil das finde ich nicht. Nein. Du darfst, wenn du Magazine anfängst zu lesen, ist es wie eine Flasche aufmachen, dann hast du sie zu kaufen, aber eine Grapefruit-Ganini aus dem Kühlobjekt kühlenden Schrank herauszunehmen, finde ich okay, wenn du es wieder reinmachst. Ich habe es auf jeden Fall bezahlt. Das ist eine schlechte Hausaufgabe. Das ist so, als hättest du die abgeschrieben, falsch abgeschrieben. So in der fünf Minuten Pause vor, also ganz ehrlich, ich tobe vor Wut gerade, schon wieder, merkst du mir vielleicht an? Ich merkst, die Lippe zittert wieder. Meine Lippe bebt und meine Faust rutscht mir fast aus, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Sie ist schon in der Luft, sie ist geballt und in der Luft und sie muss nur noch herabbleiben. Damokles-Faust über dir. Und dann habe ich bezahlt und er hat nicht lecker Fruchtsaftkonzentrat. Wie will denn sein zweites Telefon geschrien? Hat er nicht gesagt. Und dann habe ich die Lunte gerochen. Und dann dachte ich mir, so, stopp. Du hast Amkan darin geschmiert, die Lunte gerochen und ihm Parole gebietet, richtig?
Genau. Und dann dachte ich mir, Moment, vielleicht ist das der Schlüssel.
Ich habe ab dem Punkt ehrlich gesagt die Hausaufgabe vergessen, weil ich habe das Licht am Ende des Tunnels gesehen.
Du warst innen drin, du warst drin.
Ich war im Flow. Ich dachte mir, das ist meine Chance.
Was passiert, wenn ich mir am nächsten Tag eine Mate kaufe, aber ich telefoniere? Ist das der Schlüssel? Ja, jetzt wird die Haustürgabe zu so einem weirden Kunst... Das ist nämlich... Ich wollte auch meine Kunstlehrer immer verarschen. Ja, klar. Ne? Weil dann schmeißt du dir so eine Banane hin, die du in der Pause gegessen hast und sagst, hier habe Kunst, weil, und dann sagt er, ist keine Kunst, dann sage ich, doch, weil das zeigt mir, wie unachtsam unsere Generation, bla bla bla. Ja, ja, ja. Ja, das ist jetzt, was willst du mir gerade hier unterschrieben? Du machst irgendwie so eine Performanceart. Ja, nein, ich war ab dem Moment egoistisch. Ich habe unser gemeinsames Projekt, unser gemeinsames Baby, das Podcast-Uvo in den Graben
geworfen. Ich habe gesagt,
vor den Kandachen gespannt. Sagst du mir, wie es ist?
Mach jetzt dein eigenes Ding, mir egal, jeder für sich selbst.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, jetzt
telefoniere ich. Am Handy
schönes, klassisches Fake-Telefonat.
Klassisches, ja, da müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob wir es nicht vielleicht
anders machen können. Also sehr generisch.
Und habe aber tatsächlich schon angefangen zu sprechen, 20 Meter vor dem Laden, damit es authentisch ist und habe dann eine Mate gekauft, ich telefoniere, ja, kaum Augenkontakt, nur so ein Up-Nord, nur so ein Ich bin in der Situation, ganz kurz, ich muss telefonieren. Genau, aber auch mit so einem, verstehen Sie, oder? Ja, das ist gerade viel wichtiger. Genau, so ein Kurz und dann auch so, warum kaufst du nicht dann später eine Mate? Nee, nee, nee. Aber auch dann so ein Nicken, was sagt, es ist wichtiger, dass ich gerade weiter telefonieren muss und nicht mit ihnen reden kann, aber es ist nicht so wichtig, dass ich nicht währenddessen in den Kiosk laufe und was sehr unwichtiges mache. Es waren vier Dialogseiten, ohne ein Wort auszusprechen. Es war Exotext. Es war wirklich nur so, weil wenn du dieses Handy so leicht vom Ohr wegbewegst, so um diesen intimen Moment zu schaffen, so wir sind gerade unter uns und dann dieser kurze Nod, dieses wir verstehen uns, oder wir sind auf einer Seite, dann ist er auf jeden Fall dabei. Und wo er dann sieht, dass du nicht telefonierst, weil er alle Apps sieht. Handycrush offen sieht, ja. Und dann habe ich schön Marte, Marte ihm gereicht. weil er es respektiert. Und ich habe aufgejault, gejohlt, heisser Hurra gerufen, weil ich habe meine Lösung gefunden. Ich habe mein Handy gefunden, ich kann jetzt Marte einkaufen, ich bin glücklich. Ja, die Podcast-Hörer sind enttäuscht, Stefan Tietze ist enttäuscht, ich weiß, aber ich war in dem Moment egoistisch, ich habe die Ursünde begangen, ich habe nur an mich gedacht, ich habe nur an mich gedacht, ansonsten niemanden. Und deswegen muss ich sagen, Hausaufgabe nicht gemacht, aber was fürs Leben gelernt. Ja, schön, aber dafür ist die Schule nicht da. Die Schule ist dafür da, dass man Noten bekommt für Hausaufgaben, die man gemacht hat. Ja, ich akzeptiere meine Rolle als Bösewicht dieses Podcasts, ich bin der Schlechte ich bin der böse, ich bin der schlechte Einfluss, ja, nee, ich bin der schlechte Einfluss, wo man sagen kann, ich will nicht mehr, dass du das Podcast-Ufer hörst, weil Florentin ist ein schlechter Einfluss für dich, der Stefan, das ist ein ganz netter, aber Florentin, der zieht dich moralisch runter, das kannst du besser. Tut mir leid, ja. So, und wie ein richtig guter Pädagoge werde ich das jetzt selbst in die Hand nehmen. Ich werde dahin als eine dritte Person oder sagen wir mal dreitausendste Person, jetzt eben wie viele Leute da noch hingehen, und kaufe eine Mate. Und dann will ich wissen, was sagt er zu mir, bin ich auch ein lecker Mate-Opfer? Ja. Und wenn ich das bin, werde ich nochmal hingehen und selber sagen, lecker Mate. Weil das ist nämlich, das fand ich ja das viel spannende Versuchsexperiment. Ich weiß, ich habe ja auch ein schlechtes Gewissen, es tut mir auch leid, dass ich das Experiment abgebrochen habe. Aber ist es abgebrochen? Ich habe es nämlich, da wollte ich mich sagen, ich will es nicht abbrechen, ich will es irgendwann noch machen, aber ich war einfach im Rausch der Möglichkeiten, dass ich endlich für mich, weil für euch ist das ja alles eine Quatschnummer, haha, irgendwie in der U-Bahn höre ich den Podcast, hihihi, für mich das ist mein Leben.
Oh, diese Kiosk-Storyline, ja.
Nee, das ist mein Leben.
Okay, es geht hier um meine Mate, ob ich mir einen schönen Abend machen kann oder nicht.
Und deswegen musste ich in dem Moment einfach an mich selber denken, ich musste jeder für sich selbst und es tut mir mir leid, und ich war in dem Moment nicht der, den ihr kennt vom Podcast-Uf, der alles macht für seine Hörer. Aber ich möchte dieses Experiment nicht beenden. Ich will noch dranbleiben, aber ich bin zumindest, vielleicht ist es jetzt auch einfacher für mich, weil ich habe jetzt den Fallschirm mit dem Handy. Werbung. Förendin, ich bin ein bisschen schlapp. Ich bin auch ein bisschen schlapp und ich glaube, das liegt an der Jahreszeit. Und ich ernähre mich auch nicht gut. Ich ernähre mich wirklich nicht gut. Wenn ihr eins von uns wisst aus diesem Podcast, dann lässt man sich gut ernähren. Und jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, die Lösung für unser weirdes Ernährungsproblem in den Griff bekommen. Es gibt einen fantastischen Morgendrink, den man zu sich nehmen kann, der alles beinhaltet, was man braucht. 75 essentielle Vitamine und Mineralstoffe. Wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass durch deine Quatschernährung, die du auswürfelst, du alle 75 essentiellen Vitamine und Mineralien so mitkriegst? Gleich null. Und du willst mir sagen, dass dieser Drink meine generelle Leistungsfähigkeit komplett wieder stärkt, weil es auf Immunsystem, Energiehaushalt und Darmgesundheit einzahlt? Stefan, nicht nur das sage ich dir, sondern ich sage dir sogar obendrauf, dass das Ganze auch noch gut schmeckt, weniger als einen Gramm Zucker hat und für jede Art von Ernährung ideal ist, sowohl für Paleo, Keto als auch vegane Ernährung überall machbar. Wir wären nicht das Podcast-Ufu, wenn wir nicht noch was für euch hätten. Im Petto. Im Petto.
Kleines Oben drauf, Kirsche.
Denn über athleticgreens.com slash ufo bekommt ihr zu euren Athletic Greens auch noch einen kostenlosen Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 K2 obendrauf. Das ist das, was wir alle nicht bekommen im Winter, weil die Sonne nicht scheint im Winter. Dammte Sonne! Und wir uns alle schlapp fühlen und müde, aber es fehlt einfach nur Vitamin D3 und das könnt ihr auch einfach mit dem Gutschein Code UFO dazu bekommen. Ja, macht diesen Winter zu eurem energiegeladenen und gesunden Winter mit Athletic Greens. Werbung. Und ich überlege, ob das Handy nicht wirklich das Allheilmittel für alle sozialen Situationen ist. Dass du immer auch, keine Ahnung, klassisch irgendwie Handwerker im Haus, nervig, Augenkontakt, gibt man denen Brezel, gibt man denen 50 Cent, telefonieren einfach. Und jetzt kommt die Podcast-UFO-Idee, die wir umsetzen werden. Ich glaube, die ist geil. Wir brauchen eine Hotline, wo man einfach anrufen kann für Sozialflucht. Weil jetzt kannst du spielen, du bist Schauspieler, du bist geborener Schauspieler, gelernter, geborener, gelernter Schauspieler. Und deswegen kannst du das ja umsetzen, diesen Trick. Wir, damit man nicht uns alle Podcastsufferhörer, wir können das nicht. Wir können nicht spielen. Wir nehmen das Handy ans Ohr und dann fällt uns nicht ein, was wir sagen sollen. Man sieht, dass wir eine App offen haben, dass wir nicht telefonieren. Wir können nicht damit umgehen. Uns fällt kein Gespräch ein oder uns fällt nur ein sehr, sehr furchtbares Gespräch ein, was vielleicht sogar mehr Aufmerksamkeit auf uns zieht, als uns lief ist. Ja. Deswegen wäre es doch schön, eine Nummer anrufen zu können, auch um diesen Fauxpas zu vermeiden, dass man wirklich sieht, dass kein Telefonat offen ist. Wenn man ein echtes Telefonat führt, ja. Genau, und man führt ein echtes Telefonat mit jemandem. Das ist die Social Refugee Hotline. Der Name ist vielleicht irreführend. Denkst du da jetzt an einen echten Menschen oder denkst du an eine extrem weit entwickelte KI, die das übernimmt? Oder ist es so eine Folge? Erst mal stellen wir Menschen ein, die dann denken, das ist ihr Leben, das machen wir unser Leben lang und dann ersetzen wir die dann in so einer Tag-Nacht-Aktion furchtbar durch eine Ei-ei. Ja, setzen die auf die Tür und wird durch Eiweih-bei ersetzt. Durch Eiweih-bei ersetzt. Der ja auch kaum noch was zu tun hat, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja mich aber damals im Alter von acht Jahren für den krassesten Typ aller Zeiten gehalten habe und dachte, nee, ich schreibe da nichts, ich improvisiere einfach einen Monolog. Was die dümmste Idee aller Zeiten ist, ist diese extremen Stresssituationen. Man ist so nervös. So nervös, furchtbar. Dumm hat auch nicht funktioniert, egal. Und genau, und da gibt es dann immer Leute, und es gibt ja immer so bei Bewerbungsgesprächen so diese generelle Idee, dieses du musst rausstechen. Was, vielleicht muss man nicht, vielleicht, keine Ahnung. Aber das ist so, wenn Leute dich fragen, also ich glaube, gewisse dumme Ideen sind dadurch in die Welt gekommen, durch den Zwang Ratschläge zu geben. Jemand kommt auf dich zu und sagt, ich bin nervös, also Emotionen steht an erster Stelle, Emotionen,
ich bin nervös, ich habe morgen ein
Bewerbungsgespräch. Und du
willst die Emotionen auffangen
mit Ratschlägen, obwohl das vielleicht gar
nicht nötig ist, in der Regel braucht kein Mensch Ratschläge,
man will einfach nur die Emotionen gehört haben
oder gespiegelt haben oder was, aber du
sagst dann, ja, versuch irgendwie
rauszustechen oder so, einfach um Ratschlag zu geben, du hast ja selber keine Ahnung. Aber dadurch, nee hast du nicht, aber dadurch entstehen solche Ideen, dass man rausstechen muss, wobei vielleicht, ich meine, wir können ja mal reden mit Leuten, die sich damit auskennen, also anderen Leuten als dir, die irgendwie sich mit Bewerbungen auskennen und dann wirklich sagen, worauf es ankommt. Vielleicht muss man gar nicht rausstechen. Ja, vielleicht muss man nicht rausstechen. Auf jeden Fall hat diese Person, die sich beworben hat an der Schauspielschule, beschlossen, sie will herausstechen. Und hat gesagt, sie spielt einen Monolog, aber kein wirklicher Monolog, sondern Dialog, nämlich aus dem Film Nicht auflegen mit Colin Farrell. Ich weiß nicht, wie er auf Deutsch heisst, aber das ist der Film, der komplett in der
Telefonzelle spielt,
wo Colin Farrell
nicht aufliegt.
Darf er nicht, weil sonst wird er
erschossen, glaube ich, oder irgendwas anders passiert.
Sonst wird der Zug, der immer 50
fährt, wird dann schneller
abgebremst
und fährt in das Büro
des Autoren, der diese Scheiße schreibt. Sonst fällt der Kreisel um und DiCaprio wacht auf und merkt, oh, ich muss den Zug bremsen und egal. Ich muss keine 1, 2, 3 bremsen. Nicht so wichtig. Nicht so wichtig. Tatsache ist, dass er diesen Monolog gemacht hat und den Gegenpart von dem anderen, mit dem er telefoniert, auf Kassette aufgenommen hat. Und dann hat er die Kassette gestartet und hat dann immer seinen Teil gesagt, gespielt und dann kam der Teil von der Kassette, der aber komplett voraufgezeichnet war und natürlich, wie es sein musste, hat er das Timing halt komplett verhauen und war immer zu langsam, so dass der andere schon angefangen hat zu reden und er immer versucht hat, schneller zu reden als der andere, irgendwann zu schnell war, so dass eine Pause entstanden ist, bevor der andere geredet hat. Bis der andere lacht hat. Und es war eine absolute Katastrophe, es hat hin und vorher nicht funktioniert. Aber er ist herausgestochen. Er ist negativ herausgestochen, aber wo ich mir auch dachte, da sitzen dann so vier Schauspiellehrer da, die diese Prüfung abnehmen. Die erstmal schon grinsen müssen, wenn er dieses Kassetten-Ding aufhört, weil ich glaube auch nicht, dass er heraussticht. Nee, weil vor allem alle wissen, das wird nichts. Und sie gucken eigentlich nur noch zu, wie genau läuft das jetzt schien. Let it unfold. Ja, du weißt ganz genau, das wird jetzt schön. Das wird jetzt richtig schön in zehn Minuten. Und ja, so ein bisschen könnte natürlich diese Hotline auch funktionieren, dass wenn wir da irgendwas voraufzeichnen und die Person immer reinredet. Wir können ja mal gucken. Wir schaffen auch ein altes Handy finden mit einer alten Handynummer und dann können wir das ja mal anbieten. So immer so Mittwoch zwischen 16 und 17 Uhr können wir irgendwas machen. Ja, genau, also vielleicht machen wir das mal so ein kleines Fenster, das finde ich gut. Und dann wisst ihr, wenn ihr irgendeinen schweren Behördengang habt oder ihr müsst noch irgendwie dieses klassische Du bist, keine Ahnung, bei irgendeinem Tinder-Date zu Hause und da ist dann die Mutter und die schenkt dir einen Kuchen mit einem Teller. Und dann nimmst du den Kuchen mit einem Teller nach Hause.
Die One-Night-Stand funktioniert nicht und man hat keinen Kontakt mehr, hat aber noch diesen Teller und muss dann den irgendwie an die Mutter dieser Person zurückbringen und fragt dann, hey, wo wohnt deine Mutter?
Ganz unangenehme Situation, aber auch die wird einfacher dadurch, dass wenn man dann klingelt und muss halt in eine andere Stadt fahren, wo man dann klingelt, aber man telefoniert die ganze Zeit, während man dann diesen Teller zurückgibt. Richtig, genau. Und wenn ihr das wisst, dann könnt ihr sagen, hey, Frau Hubelreuth, ich komme morgen um 16 Uhr, wissend, dass da die Social Refugee, Help Social Refugees Hotline offen ist, und dann könnt ihr das da machen. Genau. Andere Idee, die Help Social Refugee Hotline ist einfach nur Werbung. Ganz, also Leute können ihre Produkte vorstellen, Leute können ihre Dienste vorstellen. Du bist direkt bei der Monetarisierung.
Ich habe direkt gedacht, wie können wir das monetarisieren und dachten wir, ja gut, wir rufen ganz viele Leute an, wir müssen ein Handy kaufen erstmal und dann müssen wir auch die ganzen Leute bezahlen, die da reden, das ist alles Quatsch. Nein, wir vergeben Spots.
So, dann laufen da meinetwegen 18 verschiedene Spots von Nike, Adidas, Puma, Umbro und so Hummel. Laufen dann alle nacheinander und du rufst da an, kannst sehr gut so tun, als ob du was hörst, weil du was hörst, du hörst schon was. Der schauspielerische Aufwand ist auf ein Minimum reduziert, du kannst auch kommentieren sogar, das gefällt mir nicht so gut, Ali, das gefällt mir besser, sowas, kannst du ja auch sagen. Ja, gut, aber ich meine, auf der anderen Seite, wenn du Werbung hören willst, kannst du auch einfach eine Folge des Podcasts Sufo hören. Das kannst du im Grunde genauso machen. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob dir das so hilft. Ich meine, es ist natürlich gut, ein Geräusch zu haben, dieses ... Vielleicht braucht man so das ... Dieses Film ... Ja genau, das wollte ich auch ... Und man fängt auch an so zu reden bild ich mir ein dass es in ernsten Filme manchmal auch das ist ja die sind animal crossing sprache aber es ist nicht simsisch es ist deutlich das ist die verpixelte version von sprache simsisch international simsisch ist nicht so verpixelt Simsisch ist furchtbar, aber nicht so verpixelt. Ja, Simsisch ist furchtbar.
Aber nicht so verpixelt.
Simsisch ist auch quasi direkt zwischen Englisch und dem.
Wobei bei den Peanuts haben die Erwachsenen ja immer so
gesprochen.
Das kann man eigentlich auch machen.
Oder so eine Unterhaltung zwischen
und
auch nicht schlecht. Wie würden wir reden bei den Peanuts? Oder so eine Unterhaltung zwischen und .
Wäre auch nicht schlecht.
Was wären wir, wie würden wir reden bei den Peanuts?
Ich glaube, du willst so.
Ich glaube, du willst.
Wie lange müssten wir so reden, bis keiner mehr zuhört?
Wir sehen ja in den Statistiken, wie viele noch immer zuhören, ab welcher Minute. Ja, richtig, ja. Wie lange müssten wir jetzt so reden, bis ... Herzlich willkommen bei Wie lange müsste man das machen, bis irgendwas anderes passiert? Oder Time Out mit Janine Kunze. Oh mein Gott. Nee, Guido Kunze Kanz. Guido Kanz, aber ich weiß nicht, ob wir das jetzt nochmal machen müssen. Ich weiß auch nicht. So viele Klagen, meine Herren. Letzte Woche war schlimm. Oder man hat eine Hotline, die einem einfach das, was man sagt, nochmal wiederholt. Oh Gott, nee, das ist das Handy meiner Mutter und das ist die schlimmste Experience. Ja, ruft Stefans Mutter an. Ich glaube, es kann Beziehungen zerstören, wenn du jemanden anrufst und du hörst dich die ganze Zeit selber. Es gibt Leute, ich glaube, ihr kennt das da draußen, es gibt manche Menschen, die haben irgendeinen komischen Defekt oder es ist mein Handy, ich weiß es nicht, ich telefoniere aber sonst mit nicht so vielen Menschen, weil ich nicht gerne telefoniere und es versuche immer auszusourcen, aber es gibt manchmal diesen Moment, dass man andauernd seine Stimme wiederhört, das ist das Schlimmste, das wird dann total aus dem Konzept, man redet dann einfach wie ein der letzte Vollidiot und ich glaube, dass meine Mutter mittlerweile denkt, ihr Sohn ist ein kompletter Idiot. Aber meinst du jetzt technisch so wie ein Echo oder dass die Person das nochmal wiederholt, was du sagst?
Nein, Echo. Es kommt ein Echo und dann ist man verwirrt und dann stockt man und dann redet man langsamer, weil man denkt, dann hört es irgendwie auf. Vielleicht ist es so eine Art Freisprechanlage oder so. Das ist furchtbar. Ich weiß nicht genau, aber jetzt eine kurze andere Idee. Telefonate outsourcen, hast du gerade gesagt, ist eine Millionen-Dollar-Idee. Einfach so eine Art Assistent, so eine SMS-Dienst und du sagst so, hey, bestell mir, naja, Pizza bestellen geht mittlerweile online, ne? Du schreibst es vor. Du sagst so Zahnarzttermin, hey, buch mir einen Zahnarzttermin bei dem und dem Zahnarzt am Dienstag zwischen 15 und 18 Uhr. Alter, Mail. Und es heißt die Mail-to-Phone. Das ist eine E-Mail-Adresse. Das ist einfach eine E-Mail-Adresse. Und man muss in den Betreff die Nummer reinschreiben, an die das Ganze gesagt werden soll. Und dann schreibst du in die Mail einfach nur den Text, den du telefonisch sagen willst. Und darunter mögliche Antworten auf Folgefragen. Naja, du musst schon beim Tarnazermin zum Beispiel Zeiträume angeben. Aber wie monetarisiert man das jetzt? Weil ich dachte, wenn du so ein... Danke, dass ich mal nicht immer nur Manni-Stefan sein muss, sondern dass du auch mal mitdenkst. Ja, aber wenn du zum Beispiel so einen SMS-Service machst und der SMS kostet ein Euro, an diese Nummer zu schicken, jede SMS ein Euro, und du kannst in die SMS schicken, die Nummer, die du anrufen willst und was geklärt werden muss. Auch so wie zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, Ebay-Kleinanzeigen.
Auch da muss man anrufen, Leute telefonieren nicht gerne und sagen einfach,
hey, handel mal auf ungefähr 50 Euro runter und sag, wann ich es abholen kann.
Und dann schreibst du SMS, drei Minuten später kommt eine SMS zurück mit,
ja, du kannst sie an der Adresse um so und so viel Uhr abholen.
Zack, ein Euro verdient. Geniale Idee. Aber dann bildet sich irgendwann so ein Pyramid-Scheme, weil ja niemand telefonieren will. Heißt, die Leute, die da arbeiten. Genau, die Mitarbeiter schicken selbst wieder eine SMS. An das System. Ja, das könnte ein Problem werden. Weil es immer noch billiger ist, weil der Aufwand in Euros aushaltbarer ist, als es willig zu machen. Und dann wäre der dann, weil der Dienst wird trotzdem benutzt. Wir schnappen uns, es gibt doch bestimmt irgendwie so Leute, so irgendwie Studenten oder sowas, die sich was dazu verdienen wollen. Aber ist es schwer, so eine Hotline aufzubauen mit einem Euro pro SMS? Das ist bestimmt nicht ganz leicht, oder? Ja, ich habe auch nie verstanden, wie das funktionieren soll. wie ProSieben diese Nummer einrichten kann, wo dann oh, die 19 Cent, die sind für das deutsche Mobilfunknetz und der Rest ist für uns, der Rest ist für die Bank. Wie baut man sowas auf? Ja, ich habe lange im Callcenter gearbeitet, da hätte ich das rausfinden können, aber ich habe mich Du hast nicht die richtigen Fragen gestellt. Ich habe Wurst gegessen den ganzen Tag. Nein, du hast die richtigen Fragen beantwortet. Richtig, ich habe keine Fragen gestellt. Sollte man nicht viel mehr Fragen stellen als beantworten? Sollte man, wenn man im Callcenter arbeitet, nicht viel, das ist meine eigentliche Frage. Sollte man, wenn man im Callcenter arbeitet, nicht lieber Fragen stellen als Antworten? Code me on this. Auch eine gute Hotline, man ruft die an und sie stellt dir Fragen. Wie geht es dir denn? Wie geht es dir denn? Nee, aber wo willst du denn eigentlich hin? Aber was war die beste Entscheidung, die du in den letzten fünf Jahren getroffen hast? Wow, das finde ich mega. Wie der Fragebogen von Max Frisch. So was. Der einfach mal ein paar Fragen stellt. Leute, wären wir gerade reich eigentlich? Ich spüre es gerade. Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass wir reich sind. Ich glaube, wir sind die Letzten in der Kälte re reich. Ja, Leute. Wir schulden uns hoch, weil wir das an den Start bringen. Und irgendwer, Stefan Zwiesel, Hörer aus Saarbrücken, wird das alles in den Nagel reißen dann. Leute, es gibt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, aber ich bin letztens in irgendwas reingerutscht, wo ich mir dachte, wow, das gibt's. Und zwar nennt sich das Crack. Freimaurer. Und das kann man kaufen. Nein, und zwar war es ein WhatsApp-Broadcast. Ja. Und es ist keine WhatsApp-Gruppe. Aber da rutschst du nicht einfach rein. Es ist keine WhatsApp-Gruppe. Entscheidungen wurden betroffen, Fehler wurden begangen. Es ist wirklich keine WhatsApp-Gruppe, wo jeder schreiben kann, sondern im Grunde ist es eine WhatsApp-Gruppe, wo nur einer schreiben kann und alle anderen sind Abonnenten und anonym.
Und du kriegst dann was geschickt.
Ja, wie ich der WhatsApp-Verlauf mit mir und meinem Crush.
Auch hier, ruf ihn an, lass ihn anrufen von Call Me Maybe.
Heißt Call Me Maybe?
Call Me Baby.
Call Me Maybe Not.
Call Me Maybe Not. Don't text me. Call me baby. Nee, call me maybe not. Call me maybe not. Text me. Text me maybe. Text me baby. Text me baby maybe. So was. Text me baby one more time und dann haben wir noch den nächsten Hit. Wir werden reich. Es sind wieder fünf URLs, die ich bestellen muss. Jede kostet 10.000 Euro. Hast du eine Ahnung, was das für eine Investition ist. Auf jeden Fall, Whatsapp Broadcast und ich habe mich bei einem Broadcast, ich möchte, weil der Broadcast ist sehr exklusiv, also ich will nicht so viel dazu sagen. Und zwar musste man da ein Codewort hinschicken und dann kriegt man Content und da kriegt man dann, ich denke mir jetzt mal irgendwas aus, um nicht auf die Identität meines Broadcasts zurückzuschliessen, Man kriegt Fotos von, na ja. Er guckt sich im Raum um. Er hat noch nichts gefunden. Er guckt sich weiter um, er sucht und seine Augen finden nichts. Obwohl, das ist, finde ich seltsam, wenn ich schon acht Dinge sagen können, weil hier stehen ein paar Dinge rum. Er sieht, er guckt auf eine Pflanze, vielleicht ist es Pflanzen-Related, die jetzt was kommt. Von schönen Stühlen zum Beispiel. Ja, so wie Schäffern-Titze in Architektur, du schreibst Stuhl-Go an eine 44844 und dann sagt er ja und dann kriegst du jeden Tag ein Bild von dem Stuhl. So funktioniert das ungefähr. Wait, wie Porn-related ist das? Nicht. Warum hast du nach rechts geguckt?
Was du immer machen, wenn du lügst?
Kein Kommentar.
Funktionieren Lügendetektoren?
Mein Mandant möchte sich nicht dazu äussern.
Jetzt weiß ich aber nicht, wo ich damit hin wollte.
Ich dachte, dass wir auch so einen WhatsApp-Broadcast machen.
Ja, gute Idee.
Machen wir einfach.
Kein Wunderplan.
Ich sehe nur die Dollarzeichen in deinen Augen, du willst wieder Werbung.
Nehmen wir überhaupt noch auf oder verlieren wir Geld gerade?
Finde ich eine gute Idee.
Du begriffst Werbung an 4844 und du kriegst irgendwas.
Und ihr kriegt Werbung.
YouTube-Werbung einfach. Hier, BMW.
Lass uns das mit dem Text-me-maybe mal einrichten, ob das klappt und dann machen wir das. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich finde es super. Text me baby one more time. Bits. Wir müssen uns auch treu bleiben, es heißt einfach Text, Text, Text, Text, Text. Text, Text, Text, Text. Text to phone, vielleicht Text to phone. Mail to phone. Was macht man denn, warum die Website? Warum dieser Zwischenschritt zur Website? Warum nicht einfach eine Mail? Warum nicht, wir schicken, man kann eine Mail an.
Ja, aber mit Mails kann man kein Geld verdienen, Stefan T. Was sage ich dir denn seit Jahren eigentlich? Du bist so unentspannt bei dem Thema mittlerweile. Was ist passiert? Weil ich damals gesagt habe, warum nicht kostenpflichtige Mails?
So, jede Mail kostet 99 Cent.
Du hast gesagt, nein, das geht nicht.
Wie soll man das machen?
Wo kriegen wir das Geld her?
Das muss irgendjemand an.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, hör auf jetzt mit deinem Quatsch, ich will dein Rumgeheul nicht mehr hören. Ich habe Animal Crossing gespielt.
Zahl mich aus, gib mir 50% meiner Idee, das ist eine 100 Millionen Dollar Idee, die gehört zur Hälfte dir, zur Hälfte mir.
Wenn du das hier zuhörst, musst du mich aus, gib mir 50% meiner Idee. Das ist eine 100-Million-Dollar-Idee, die gehört zur Hälfte dir, zur Hälfte mir. Wenn du das hier zuhörst, musst du mich auszahlen, musst du mir 50 Millionen Dollar geben und dann kannst du hier raus. Das ist ein Sprichwort. Nein, bis dahin will ich nichts mehr davon hören. Und weil wir auch schon lange nichts mehr gehört haben, ist einer der vielleicht schönsten Kontinente dieser Erde. Ich bin in meinen Top-5-Kontinenten immer dabei.
Ist bei mir mittlerweile auch in die Top-5 gerutscht.
Natürlich sprechen wir von Afrika.
Und falls ihr denkt, was ist das denn?
Was haben die gerade gesagt? Spielen wir mal zurück.
Afrika. Und falls ihr davon noch nicht gehört habt, was ist das denn?
Falls ihr euch fragt, was soll das?
Haben wir eine kleine Rubrik für euch vorbereitet, nämlich Antenne Afrika. Ja, in Antenne Afrika. vielleicht schon so ein bisschen habt ihr in den letzten Tagen vielleicht die Nachrichten verfolgt, da habt ihr Amerika gesehen, die USA, da gab es viele Staaten. Und viele von euch denken, dass die USA ein Land sind. Das ist nicht richtig. Es sind 50 Länder und die, das können wir nach Antenafrika machen, aber unter Europa ist dieses große, wie wir alle immer dachten, Fleckchen Land, Fleckchen Erde.
Nein, es sind 55 individuelle Staaten, die jeweils auch Biden oder Trump gewählt hätten, wenn sie gefragt worden wären.
Niemand hat sie angerufen.
Aber wir haben für euch nachgeguckt, Afrika ist noch da, keine Angst, macht euch keine Sorgen.
Und wir haben schon einige Länder kennengelernt, wie zum Beispiel Burkina Faso. Um nur eins zu nennen, um nur eins zu nennen, um nur eins zu nennen. Und heute lernen wir ein anderes kennen. Und vielen Dank für alle Einsendungen. Wir haben noch ein paar in der Hinterhand. Könnt gerne aufhören, falls ihr welche einschicken wollt. Fragt bitte kurz davor, ob das Land schon genommen wurde oder nicht. Die meisten Länder sind schon weg in Afrika, das kennt man leider, wenn man zu spät dran ist, dann sind die alle schon weggenommen worden. Das ist das Nervigste. Immer unangenehm. Aber ich würde sagen, heute würde ich sagen, hören wir mal rein. Die schönsten sind weg. Das kennt man. Wenn man es von einer Seite kennt, dann von Afrika.
Dass die Guten schon weg sind. Das ist wie so eine Schachtel Messi. Bevor du die aufmachst, weißt du schon, die Guten sind schon weg. Die Guten in Küstennähe und die rohstoffreichen Männer sind weg. Aber es sind noch ein paar übrig. Gute Nachrichten an euch, es sind noch ein paar übrig, wie zum Beispiel Senegal. Und wenn du jetzt sagst, mir egal, dir egal, Senegal, dann sage ich, ja, da seid ihr immer völlig falsch gewickelt, Freunde.
Denn Senegal ist ein tolles Land. Und warum, Eh, Ksumay, Ksumaylama, Bacadalumi, Engabo, Sumo-Le, Ibig, Salah, Savo-i, Alunka, Engabo, Ksumay, Ksumaylama, Yo! Das war eine Mischung aus Französisch, Mandinka, Arabisch und Karon, vier der neunzehn Sprachen, die in Senegal gesprochen werden. Tatsächlich kann man im Senegal und in Senegal sagen. Übersetzt bedeutet das Ganze so viel wie Hallo, wie geht's. Wenn man nach Senegal geht, sollte man die Begrüssungen mit den passenden Antworten lernen, weil auch der ganze Tag mit Begrüssen verbracht wird. Das Ganze geht auch mehrmals am Tag. Wir sind Eisertow und Leonie, sind Halbsenegal-Lesenden und können inzwischen nach 20 Jahren Übung die Begrüssung fast fehlerfrei. Der Senegal liegt im Westen Afrikas am Atlantik. Die Hauptstadt ist Dakar, die westlichste Stadt des afrikanischen Kontinents. Bis 1960 war der Senegal wie die meisten westafrikanischen Staaten eine französische Kolonie. Senegal umschliesst Gamia, das kleinste Land Afrikas. Während der Norden von trockenem Wüstenklima geprägt ist, herrscht in der Casamance, dem Süden Senegals, ein tropisch reuchtes Klima. Hier wachsen Früchte wie Mangos, Bananen und Orange. Auch Erdnüsse, Cashews, Pokusnüsse und das Achenbrot der Baobadbäume nähren. Das Nationalgericht ist Tchibu-Tschen, was Wolof ist und auf Deutsch reissen Fisch bedeutet. Dies wird in den unterschiedlichsten Variationen zugereitet. Hier noch ein paar Random-Farm-Facts. Wenn man wissen will, wo sich eine Person auffällt, wird einfach ein Le an den Namen angehängt, Stefan Le bedeutet also so viel wie Wo ist Stefan? In Senegal gibt es das unaufgeschriebene Gesetz, dass man ein Tier, das man im Strassenverkehr anfährt, behalten darf. Allgemein ist der Verkehr in Senegal eine wilde Sache, so fahren auf Motorräder so viele Menschen mit, wie man draufbrechen kann. Familienrekord bei uns uns sind vier Erwachsene. Nur der Fahrer braucht einen Helm, und in Autos haben nur Fahrer und Beifahrer Anschnallpflicht. Auf der Rückbank sitzen meistens eh so viele Menschen, dass Anschnallen überflüssig wird. Wenn an einem Auto kein Platz mehr für Gepäck und die Einkäufe ist, wird es aufs Dach geschnürt. So kommt es nicht selten vor, dass lebendige Tiere die Fahrt auf dem Dach verbringen. Die senegalesische Uhr haben wir nach zwanzig Lebensjahren immer noch nicht erfasst. Hier ein paar Faustregeln. Ein Fussballspiel beginnt erst dann, wenn der letzte Fan eingetroffen ist. Silvesterparty ab zwanzig Uhr am Strand heisst übersetzt, zwanzig Uhr, leerer Strand, keiner da. 21 Uhr beginnt mit dem Aufbau, um 23.50 Uhr beginnt dann das Programm, mitternacht wird einfach ignoriert. Wir sind losgezogen und haben unsere Familie gefragt, warum sollten die Podcast-Ufo-Hörer nach Senegal fliegen? Senegal ist echt vielseitig. Senegals Städte präsentieren das innovativ moderne Afrika, während in den Dörfern noch die alten Traditionen gewahrt werden, wie Trommeln, Tänze und bunte Gewände. Also ich finde, in Senegal sind die Menschen besonders gut drauf und besonders hübsch. In Senegal und in Tuzer-Enssemble. Mega! Ja, vielen Dank an Leonie und Aissa Tu für diesen fantastischen Beitrag aus Senegal. Wir haben viel gelernt, ganz fantastisch finde ich natürlich, dass... Tiere können behalten werden, wenn die angefahren werden. Tier anfasst, darfst du es behalten, was natürlich dafür sorgt, dass wenn du irgendwo eine niedliche Katze siehst, einfach mal ihr den ganzen Tag hinterher fährst und versuchst sie anzufahren. Und nicht nur du, sondern auch die halbe andere Stadt, wo die dann versucht, diese scheiß Katze anzufahren, damit du die behalten kannst.
Das heißt, du kannst einfach, wenn irgendwie Kühe auf einem Feld stehen, die einem Bauern gehören, holst du einfach dein Auto und fährst jede Kuh einmal an und packst sie dann aufs Dach, hat sie ja auch beschrieben, lebende Tiere kommen aufs Dach und dann haust du ab mit dem Kühen. so einen stolzen, grossen Condor würde ich mir anfliegen beim Flugzeug und dann fliege ich und dann siehst du mich im Senegal, da habe ich so einen grossen, der gehört es mir und das Tier muss auch, weil es ja auch so ein ungeschönes Gesetz ist. Ja, das ist so wie so ein Dobby dann. Ja, das ist so, ja okay und dann wie bei Avatar habe ich dann so einen grossen Adler, der mich dann immer von A nach B fliegt. Finde ich cool. Wie ist das denn in Deutschland, wenn ich jetzt in Deutschland ein Reh anfahre, wer hält mich davon ab, dass das jetzt meins ist? Ich glaube, ist es Diebstahl, wenn ich so ein Reh mitnehme? Ja. Von wem denn? Mutter Natur oder was? Da sitzt dann irgendwie so ein Käfer im Gericht und verklagt mich. Und Mutter Natur und Fädelchen Frost werden Sau auf die Seite. Bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ist das wirklich Diebstahl? Ich glaube, es ist nicht okay. Aber wenn du einen Hund hast und ich klaue den, ich glaube, das ist egal. Das ist nicht egal. Das ist schon egal.
Vor Gericht, das ist nicht egal.
Das ist schon egal.
Also es steht nicht im Text, von daher ist es
egal. Ich glaube, wenn an der Tür,
an einem Türklingel-Schild steht, der Hund mit
draufsteht, als Teil der Familie.
Hier wohnen Anna, Thomas, Sabine
und Boris der Hund.
Dann glaube ich, ist es verboten, den einzustecken. Weil wenn du den kaputt trittst, wenn du den Hund tot trittst, ist das ja Sachbeschädigung. Sachbeschädigung? Sachbeschädigung, womit vor Gericht klar ist, Hunde sind egal, ob es ein Koffer ist oder ein Hund, ob es ein Plüschhund ist, den du kaputt machst, oder ein echter Hund, ist egal, ist erstmal dieselbe Strafe. Würde man eher verknackt werden dafür, einen beliebten Plüschhund zu töten oder einen unbeliebten Hund. Angenommen. Ja, da braucht es Präzedenzfälle, da müssen die Juristen noch mal zu Wort melden, die kaum noch anrufen. Aber ja, kann schon sein. Kann schon sein. Beliebter Stoffhund.
Ja, kriegt man mehr Geldstrafen, wenn man einen beliebten Hund,
unbeliebten Hund und einen beliebten Plüschhund umbringt?
Weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist ja beides Sachbeschädigung.
Du, da musst du mal wieder dich in Gericht setzen und zugucken.
Ja, vielen, vielen Dank für diesen kleinen Ausflug nach Senegal.
Auch gut, dass die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund getrommelt wurde, wirklich.
Ist sehr laut in Senegal. Also es hat es nicht attraktiv gemacht, die Vorstellung, dass konstant Lärm ist im Hintergrund. Dass konstant getrommelt wird, einmal mal kurz Stille, aber nur um dann gleich wieder loszulegen, war es mir sympathisch. Und eins, zwei, drei, vier, weiter und man hat auch mal so diese eine Zählweise. Ich finde das mega, also Trommelmusik, ich stelle mir da nie, ich stelle mir da immer eine gute Laune vor, auch weil ich mir niemanden vorstellen kann, der nicht lächelnd trommelt. Denk mal an das Prinzip des Trommelns. Das stimmt nicht ganz. Also so Orchestermitglieder, Perkussionisten, die immer mit den grossen Augen zum Dirigenten gucken, weil sie natürlich einen Einsatz, den sie haben im 80 Minuten langen Song von Beethoven, nicht verpassen wollen. so, sonst, so Congas trommeln kann man nicht, ohne breit zu grinsen. Das geht nicht. Es macht so Spaß, die Bewegung alleine schon. Und deswegen fand ich das schön für diesen Beitrag. Immer darüber wird getrommelt, ich verbinde gute Laune mit Senegal. Auf jeden Fall, finde ich auch gut. Und auch direkt für dich am Anfang gesagt, man kann im Senegal und in Senegal sagen. Genau, der Senegal oder Senegal. Ja, und zum ersten Mal konnte sich Bluhrendin auf einen Beitrag konzentrieren, weil er nicht von den grammatikalischen Fragen gequält. Nee, das ist gut, wenn das so geklärt wird, wenn man einfach sagt, so ist es jetzt. Ja, ja. Ich sage nur, du kannst dich auch direkt auf den Inhalt konzentrieren und musst nicht immer diesen grammatikalischen Fragen hinterher rennen. Aber wie ist, also darf man dann nicht der Kongo sagen, oder was? Vielen Dank an euch beiden, euch drei, euch vier. Wer hält mich davon ab, der Kongo zu sagen? Wer hält mich zurück? Wer packt mich am Unterarm und sagt, nur weil du es sagen kannst, heißt es nicht, dass du es solltest. Und nur weil du einen Hund klauen kannst, heißt es nicht, dass du es solltest. Jetzt habt ihr mal einen kleinen Eindruck bekommen von dem Moral, Stefan, der mich hier jede Woche terrorisiert, der mir nach der Folge noch mal erklärt, was man alles nicht machen darf. Ja, der angeht, wenn die Folge ausgeht. Das ist wie so eine Schachuhr, wo wenn die eine Uhr aufhört, geht die andere automatisch an. Man kann das nicht pausieren. Aber man mag beide nicht und deswegen drückt man konstituiert nicht auf mich drauf. Ja. Vielen Dank an euch und das heißt, wir haben ein weiteres Land dazu bekommen. Genau, falls ihr denkt, oh, ich kenne mich auch mit einem Land Afrikas gut aus, dann schickt mir bitte kurz eine Mail, ob da schon ein Beitrag dazu vorliegt. Wir wollen ja keine Doppelung haben. Das wäre ja ganz schlimmste. Ich kann mir nichts Schlimmeres vorstellen, als zweimal was über den Sinniger als höher. Wir wissen in der Geschichte, dass wenn mehrere Leute dasselbe afrikanische Land ansprechen, dann gibt es unangenehme Situationen. Lass uns das doch bitte aus der Geschichte lernen und einfach davor mal anklopfen und sagen, ist hier schon jemand? Nein, dann komme ich. So, was wir auch aus der Geschichte gelernt haben, dann, dass dieses peinliche, ich packe mein Kofferspiel, doch bitte zu lassen ist, oder nicht? Ich würde gerade einen Punkt machen. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich nehme mit und ich kolonialisiere Namibia und Uganda. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich wertschätze Namibia, Uganda und Tansania. Ich lerne Länder Afrika und ich möchte am meisten wissen über Namibia, Uganda, Tansania und Äthiopien. Ich liebe die Länder Afrikas und ich lerne über Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien und Sambia. So, oder? Ja. Oder kam erst Rom? Nee, Rom kam erst. Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien, Sambia und nagelt mich nicht drauf fest, Ruanda. Nee, kam nicht erst Puki? So. Okay, dann, also, ich packe meinen Roller und packe darauf. Und packe aufs Dach. Packe aufs Dach. Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, wir brauchen so einen Rhythmus. Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien, Sambia, Ruanda, Burkina Faso. Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien, Nambia, Ruanda, Burkina Faso, Senegal. Sehnegal, wow. Wir wissen ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob das stimmt, nen, nen, nen, nen, Das sieht nämlich wie so ein Off-Brand, wie Burger King zu McDonald's ist. So ein Off-Brand Disney World.
Ja, so ein bisschen wie Digimon zu Pokémon irgendwie. Man sagt so, ja, okay. Klingt und klingt zugleich. Also so Ducktales, Looney Tunes, war ja eigentlich nicht verstanden. Nee, ist zu kompliziert. Aber vielleicht wird es gut. Ich hätte mal auch wieder Lust auf so eine knackige Serie, die mich richtig packt. Schaust du Barbarians, Die Barbaren? Ich habe nicht Die Barbaren geschaut. Ich habe mich zunächst auf andere Sachen fokussieren wollen. Ich bin gerade ein bisschen im HBO-Dschungel eingetaucht. Bist du jetzt über Nordic unterwegs? Wie ich es geschafft habe, I Be Gone in the Dark zu gucken, auch viele Nachrichten von Florentin bekommen. Dann gibt es auch eine ganz tolle Serie, ich habe den Namen vergessen, How To heißt die, meine ich nur, über einen ganz tollen Comedian, dessen Name mir auch einfallen ist. Wow, das ist echt der Empfehlungsmeister. Es wurde produziert von Nathan Fielder, den ich ja sehr mag. Aber wie schaffst du es jetzt, HBO zu schauen? Und HBO zu gucken, schaffe ich über HBO Nordic. HBO Nordic, das hat mir auch nicht geklappt. Ich bin auf die Website von HBO Nordic gegangen und da hieß es, nee, nicht für sie zugänglich. Nee, ihr müsst, glaube ich, nach Skandinavien reisen, da einen Account anlegen und dann könnt ihr das unbegrenzt benutzen. Aber in Deutschland kann man es ohne VPN tatsächlich einfach so benutzen. Ich benutze es tatsächlich über einen Freund, der es in Schweden sicherlich gemacht hat. Also da gibt es schon Möglichkeiten, es gibt Wege und Möglichkeiten, viele Wege führen nach HBO. Aber auch nach Rom und in Barbarians geht es ja um die Römer, die da gegen die Germanen kämpfen und die Römer sprechen alle Latein.
Nein, das finde ich fantastisch.
Und das ist nicht zu knapp, also Hauptfiguren sind Römer und es gibt auch viele Szenen da und die sprechen alle Latein tatsächlich.
Das ist echt cool, das macht schon was her. Über die Serie kann man jetzt streiten, ob die gut ist oder nicht, muss jeder selber entscheiden.
Aber das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt. es gibt auch viele Szenen da, und die sprechen alle Latein tatsächlich. Das ist echt cool, das macht schon was her. Über die Serie kann man jetzt streiten, ob die gut ist oder nicht, muss jeder selber entscheiden, aber das fand ich schon einen coolen Move, weil ich mir dachte, ganz alle Lateinlehrer der Welt schreien auf und sagen, endlich haben wir mal eine coole Serie, die wir mit Lateinlehrer das lateinische Wort für ja! Ja! Und ich bin total im Lateinhype, wenn man sowas, also ich kann, Sig Est kann ich, das ist so wie, ja und, stimmt das, passt es, was machen wir? Wie ist es? Ist es so, ist das so? Ja, wie läuft's? Habe ich das richtig verstanden? Sig Est, sage ich jetzt häufig im Alltag, Sig Est kann man immer gut einbauen und richtig cool auf jeden Fall. Klar, das finde ich auch cool, das ist ja genau, wir haben ja schon darüber gesprochen, bei Herr der Ringe, als Herr der Ringe gedreht wurde, da hat New Line Cinema oder die Produktion irgendwann mal so einen Experten für elbische Sprache kontaktiert. Und der Tag muss der schönste in seinem ganzen Leben gewesen sein. Du lernst elbische Sprache, kennst dich aus und es heißt, jetzt wird ein Film gedreht, du hast jetzt endlich mal eine echte Aufgabe. Und genau so müssen die Leute sich gefühlt haben, die Latein-Experten, die gesagt haben, weil niemand weiss ja, wie man Latein ausgesprochen hat. Das würde ja nicht, würde irgendwie festgehalten. Mein Lateinärer wusste das. Gut, klar. Nicht zu knapp. Das ist natürlich dann die Frage, wie spricht man das aus, wie kann man das rekonstruieren, da gibt es auch tolle YouTube-Videos, falls euch das interessiert. Klingt das so, wie man es erwartet? Da hast du natürlich das alte Wasserleichenproblem.
Macht man es realistisch,
was für viele Hörer vielleicht falsch klingt, weil sie sich Latein
anders vorstellen, weil sie denken, es klingt so wie Harry Potter
Zaubersprüche und dann erwarten sie eine
Alte-Erwartungshaltung. Es klingt aber eigentlich eher wie
Spanisch oder so oder Italienisch,
weiß man nicht. Auch da hast du das alte Wasserleichenproblem.
Also ganz viele interessante Dinge wurden
da, also habe ich mir vorgestellt. Was heißt Wasserleiche auf Latein? Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht. Auch da hast du das alte Wasserleichen-Problem. Also ganz viele interessante Dinge wurden da, also habe ich mir vorgestellt.
Was heißt Wasserleiche auf sein?
Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht.
Aqua di, Aqua, Agua di Giorgio.
Aqua Mortus.
Agua di Giorgio.
Agua di Mortue, Mortue.
Weiss ich nicht genau, aber tolle Serie, allein dafür kamen wir reingucken, finde ich immer cool.
Haben die dann auf Latein gespielt oder wurde es nachher über so ein Kredit auf Latein?
Die haben auf Latein gespielt tatsächlich.
Wahnsinn. Finde ich auch cool, so eine Rolle, weil im Grunde kann man da nicht viel falsch machen. Bitte? Also weil niemand versteht es ja so. Du bist ja auch gelernter Schauspieler. Betont ist und gespielt ist, weiß man auch nicht genau. Aber ich finde es auf jeden Fall cool. Mega. Das freut mich jetzt, dann würde ich gerne mal reinschauen. Schau einfach mal rein, guck mal, ob es dir gefällt. Die Serien, die ich schaue, die sind alle in Sprachen, belanglosen, lebenden Sprachen. Ja. Meine Serienempfehlung wäre We Are Who We Are von Luca Guadagno. Warum sind deine Serienempfehlungen immer so schwer auszusprechen? Immer I Be Gone in the Dark, wo ich ständig Nachrichten bekomme und ich habe es mir jetzt dreimal angehört, ich verstehe nicht, was Stefan da sagt. I'll Be Gone in the Dark. I'll Be Gone in the Dark. I'll Be Gone in the dark. Dann How to und jetzt noch mal bitte.
We are who we are.
We are who we are, okay.
Auch HBO Nordic kann keine Sau anschauen.
Richtig, fucking BO.
Aber die gibt es auch woanders zu gucken.
Nervigst, was man machen kann.
Ihr könnt auch auf iTunes. Doch, man kann sie gucken.
Erst mal so.
Erst mal man kann, hallo. Man kann sie gucken, Florentin, guck mich an, guck mich an, man kann sie gucken, du kannst sie schon gucken, so, verstehst du? Ja, okay. Man kann sie gucken. Okay. Ja, man kann sie gucken. Was ist das für eine Handbewegung? Du kannst sie gucken. Das ist, du, du stilgst, als würdest du so einen Würfelbecher hochnehmen und umdrehen.
Ja, das ist ein Hütchentrick.
Du kannst sie gucken.
Okay.
Ja, das war der Richtige.
Das zum einen.
Und zum anderen glaube ich, iTunes US hat die auch alle.
Übrigens, da kurzer Anschluss, falls sich Leute fragen, ob das geklappt hat, meine Skype-Nachricht an diesen... Keine Mail kam vorrufen. Niemand wollte es wissen. Niemand will wissen, wie es an dieser Story dann weitergeht. Keiner an den Fall gestellt. Er ist richtig. Dann wird das auch jetzt erstmal begraben. Aber weißt du was? Ich würde es gerne wissen. Ich würde gerne wissen, wie es aussieht. Ich habe meine Mail bekommen und alles ist gut.
Habt eine schöne Woche und wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder. Bis dann.
Dramaturgie-Ufo. Wie immer, macht's gut, tschau, tschau.